ان من الناس من وقف صدفه الى جهه الشرق
فكان مصيره ان يوضع مجبرا في عربات هجرت
اهالي حيفا الى محطات عده كان اخرها مخيم
جنين
[موسيقى]
عند زاويه التاريخ هذه تحديدا عند زاويه
البنك العثماني في حيفا والتي كانت مملوكه
ولا تزال لعزيز الخياط احد اغنى الشخصيات
في المدينه قبل عام 48 وبعده وقع حدث
[موسيقى]
تعرفون هذه الفيديوهات التي يصور اصحابها
انفسهم وهم يقفون عند حدود دولتين يضعون
كل قدم في دوله مثل هولندا وفيلجيكا مثلا
هنا في شارع الملوك في حيفا لدينا ذات
الخط الذي حدد مصائر اجيال كامله تعالوا
احدثكم
الان سنذهب عند تقاطع الطرق الاكبر الذي
تم تجميعه اهالي حيفا في قبل تهجيرهم
بدقائق
بعد اشهر من المقاومه الشرسه لم تنتهي الا
بانتهاء ذخيره الثوار في حيفا حشر الناس
كانه يوم الحشر في هذا المكان الذي يشبه
تقاطع الطرق وهو ان صح الوصف نقطه التقاء
مركزيه بين احياء المدينه الرئيسيه من
اجبر على النزول من وادي الصليب جاء من
جنوب المدينه اما حي الحلص والبوابه
الشرقيه فجاءوا من شرقها اما الجنوب
الغربي فقد حمل اهالي وادي النسناس واهالي
وادي الجمال بقي الشمال بوابه البحر
والذي يسمى اليوم ببوابه بالمر وهو
المهندس البريطاني الذي صمم وبنى ميناء
حيفا الانتداب
[موسيقى]
هذه اللافته التي وضعت هنا في احد زوايا
هذا المكان التقاطع الطرق الكبير الذي
طبعا كان يعرف باسم ساحه الفرير لان هذا
المبنى اقيم مكان مدرسه الفرات كتب عليه
ان قوات الهجنات التقت في هذا المكان قدمت
من اعالي المدينه وحسمت المعركه في هذه
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الجنود الانجليز وقفوا عند زوايا المدينه
واجبروا الناس على النزول باتجاه الميناء
يحملون بنادقهم ويصرخون
وصوت الرصاص يعلو فوق رؤوس الناس وذهولهم
الناس وكثافتهم تفرقت بعض العائلات منهم
الرقبه شرقا واخرون وقفوا غربا غير مدركين
ان مصير مختلفا سيلاقيهم بعد دقائق من هذا
الشارع هنا اجبرت الناس على النزول الى
بوابه البحر
ان من الناس من وقف صدفه الى جهه الشرق
فكان مصيره ان يوضع مجبرا في عربات هجرت
اهالي حيفا الى محطات عده كان اخرها مخيم
جنين واما من وقف الى جهه الغرب فدفعته
القوات الاحتلال الى جهه البحر
لتنتظره المراكب الانجليزيه وليصبح قبل
عصر الثاني والعشرين من ابريل عام 48
لاجئا في لبنان
[موسيقى]
وحتى يعيد التاريخ تشغيل المشهد الى
الوراء ويسحب خطه الوهمي من بيننا فلنحفظ
الاسماء جيدا هذه احدى بوابات البحر وهذا
شارع الملوك وهذه عماره البنك العثماني
يليها شارع يافا فساحه الفرير شارع ستان
كوادي الصليب المدينه وان افرغت من اهلها
ضمن ابشع عمليه تهجير قصري واحتلال
لبلادنا الا ان قلبها النابض مازال ينتظر